In the red corner, weighing in at 36 solar
masses, the reigning champion,
Big brother black hole clone!
In the blue corner, weighing in at 29 solar
masses, the challenger,
Little brother black hole clone!
It’s going to be an epic fight.
How will it end?
Let’s find out with some physics!
Hey Crazies.
Some of you were wondering if I was ever going
to do a video on Gravitational Waves.
Well now’s the time!
I realize the hype is over and there are already
tons of videos about this,
but there are still some connections that
need to be made
and some very misleading visuals that need
to be addressed.
Plus it doesn’t hurt to get your information
from multiple sources.
Especially with something this weird and crazy.
So let’s get back to those black-hole clones!
As the black-hole clones circle each other,
they move closer and closer and speed up in
the process.
Eventually, there’s a connection, does one
go down for the count?
No, don’t be ridiculous! This is astrophysics.
The two combine into one giant black-hole
clone.
They’re like a cosmic Voltron!
Voltron.
Defender of the Universe?
Very successful cartoon?
Someone has to know Voltron.
I’m so old.
Anyway, the combined giant black-hole clone
is 62 solar masses,
which might leave you thinking:
Isn’t 36 + 29 = 65, not 62?
And why weren’t their orbits stable?
Both very good questions and both have the
same answer:
Gravitational waves!
See, waves are a big deal because they move
energy from one place to another
without having to move matter from one place
to another.
That’s the definition of a wave.
They’re so useful that not 1 but 2 of our
senses have evolved to detect them.
Mechanical Waves are waves in matter
like strings, air, the Earth, or water.
Those are the kind you think of when I say
the word "wave."
Light is also a wave, but in electric and
magnetic fields instead of matter.
We did a whole video on light if you’re
interested!
Since there isn’t a lot of matter in space,
light was the only way we were able to find
astronomical stuff.
Stars like the Sun emit visible light, so
we can see them,
but planets like Jupiter don’t, so we have
to wait for light from the Sun
to get there, bounce off, and then come to
Earth before we can see it.
Unfortunately, not everything can emit or
reflect enough light.
Black Holes and Neutron Stars, for example.
Sometimes we get lucky and those things pull
in matter that we can see,
but otherwise we’re left in the dark.
That’s why gravitational waves are such
a big deal.
They’re a whole new type of wave.
Wiggles in the fabric of space-time itself,
but that means they act a little differently
than other types of waves,
so let’s be careful.
For something one-dimensional like this string,
you only need one number to represent its
curvature.
For curvature on a two-dimensional surface,
you also only need one number,
but the same cannot be said for higher dimensions.
So this is a terrible graphic for space-time.
For curvature within of a three-dimensional
space, you need 6 numbers.
For curvature within a four-dimensional space-time
like our universe,
you need 20 numbers,
which results in 10 independent Einstein equations.
Those equations describe all of the curvature
that results in gravitational motion.
But not all curvature creates waves.
You can’t have anything that’s spherically
or cylindrically symmetric,
so a lonely spinning black hole probably isn’t
going to do it,
but two black holes orbiting each other will,
just like our black-hole clones from early.
And that’s exactly what LIGO detected on
September 14th, 2015.
What’s LIGO?
The coolest thing to happen in experimental
physics since the LHC!
LIGO stands for Laser Interferometer Gravitational-wave
Observatory.
They detect gravitational waves using lasers.
About 1.3 billion years ago, a 36 solar-mass
black-hole and a 29 solar-mass black-hole
collided to form a 62 solar-mass black-hole,
releasing gravitational waves carrying 3 solar-masses
worth of energy
and then those waves traveled 1.3 billion
light years to get to Earth.
How do we know all of that?
OK, I guess that’s a fair question.
The easiest information to get from a wave
is frequency and energy.
But that’s plenty if you can do some physics.
The frequency of the wave is twice the orbital
speed of black holes.
Using general relativity, orbital speed gives
us the masses of the black holes.
and those masses tell us the energy they’re
going to lose during the merger.
That energy spreads thinner the farther it
travels, until it finally arrives at LIGO.
Comparing the predicted energy to the energy
LIGO actually received
gives us the distance to the black holes.
Direction is a little harder.
We don’t aim LIGO like a telescope.
It just sits there on the surface of the Earth
and monitors all directions at once,
which is partly why we made two different
observatories.
One is in Louisiana and the other is in Washington
state.
Louisiana detected the event a whole 7 milliseconds
before Washington.
And since we know gravitational waves travel
at the speed of light,
we can get a direction.
Well, roughly anyway.
LIGO could only narrow down the location of
the merger to an area of the sky,
measuring 600 square degrees, which is a little
under 1% of the sky.
But that’s pretty impressive considering
it monitors
out to 5 billion light years using 2.5 mi
long vacuum tubes
containing lasers that change in length by
a fraction of the width of a proton.
And since LIGO showed proof of concept, other
countries are now building their own,
which is going to make our measurements much more
precise.
It’s a great time to be alive!
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like
to see more science like this.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.